(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre os leilões judiciais de direitos do imóvel.
Existem dois casos mais comuns, que são os direitos do fiduciante e os direitos
do prometente comprador.
Vamos começar aqui com os direitos do fiduciante.
Contrato de alienação fiduciária, como a gente já bem sabe, pois o módulo 2 foi
exclusivo sobre esse assunto, é aquele em que o devedor fiduciante transfere a
propriedade resolúvel do imóvel ao credor fiduciário como forma de garantia
para o pagamento de uma dívida.
Durante o contrato de alienação fiduciária, o devedor fiduciante fica com a
posse do imóvel e o proprietário mesmo é o credor fiduciário.
Quando esse contrato está em vigência, é inegável falar que o devedor
fiduciante tem direitos sobre aquele imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque basta que ele pague a integralidade daquele contrato, que ele vai ser o
proprietário indefinitivo do imóvel.
A alienação fiduciária vai ser cancelada na matrícula daquele imóvel e o
devedor volta a ter a propriedade plena.
Então, enquanto o contrato está ali valendo, que o devedor vem pagando as suas
parcelas, ele também tem direitos de aquisição, pois a soma das parcelas pagas
com as parcelas que serão pagas vão dar ao devedor fiduciante o direito de
cancelar a alienação fiduciária e ficar indefinitivo como proprietário daquele
imóvel.
Esse devedor fiduciante pode ter dívidas cobradas judicialmente.
Então, vamos supor que o devedor fiduciante tenha uma empresa e seja processado
na Justiça Trabalhista por não pagar as verbas de seus funcionários.
Pode ser que ao final desse contrato, quando de fato o devedor for condenado a
pagar um valor aos funcionários, que a Justiça tente encontrar bens nesse
devedor para que aquela dívida que foi condenada judicialmente seja paga.
E a gente já sabe que existe aquela ordem de bens do devedor que deve ser usada
para quitar as dívidas de um devedor.
Em primeiro lugar, sempre o dinheiro em espécie ou aplicado em instituição
financeira.
E aí depois vai passando e a gente já sabe que o imóvel entra nessa ordem e
também pode ser penhorado para que dívidas do proprietário sejam pagas.
Mas vamos lá, o devedor fiduciante não é proprietário, mas ele tem direitos de
aquisição sobre aquele imóvel porque basta que ele pague o valor integral ali
que ficou acordado com o credor fiduciário que a alienação fiduciária será
cancelada na macrícula e o devedor fiduciante vai ser o proprietário daquele
imóvel.
Então ele tem esses direitos de aquisição.
E é inegável falar que esses direitos de aquisição têm valor econômico.
Porque veja, o devedor vem pagando as parcelas daquele imóvel.
Então é inegável falar que ele tem direitos de aquisição e que esses direitos
de aquisição também têm poder econômico porque basta que ele quite a
integralidade do contrato que ele vai ter o imóvel para ele e o imóvel tem
valor econômico.
Então o que a justiça pode determinar?
A justiça pode determinar que esses direitos do devedor fiduciante sejam
penhorados para que esse imóvel seja levado a leilão e aí sim uma dívida que
foi condenada judicialmente possa ser paga.
Isso acarreta o leilão judicial de direitos do devedor fiduciante.
Exatamente porque ao final do contrato de alienação fiduciária o devedor
fiduciante irá retomar a propriedade plena e durante o contrato o devedor tem
direitos de aquisição da propriedade.
Basta que ele pague a dívida em aberto que ele tem ali com o credor fiduciário.
Qual é a consequência de participar de um leilão judicial de direitos do
fiduciante?
O credor fiduciário em primeiro lugar necessariamente deve ser intimado do
processo do leilão.
Por quê?
Porque quando existe um contrato de alienação fiduciária quem é de fato
proprietário daquele imóvel é o credor fiduciário e como proprietário ele
precisa saber que o imóvel dele está sendo levado a leilão.
Então o credor fiduciário necessariamente deve ser intimado no processo
judicial e sobre a existência do leilão dos direitos do fiduciante.
E qual é a consequência para quem arremata o imóvel em leilão judicial de
direitos do fiduciante?
O arrematante ficará no lugar do devedor fiduciante assumindo os direitos e
obrigações do devedor fiduciante.
Então vamos lá, assumindo os direitos e obrigações do devedor fiduciante.
O que isso significa?
O arrematante vai assumir aquelas parcelas que o devedor fiduciante já pagou ao
credor e vai poder ficar na posse do imóvel, só que o arrematante vai ter que
assumir as obrigações do devedor fiduciante e isso inclui quitar o resto do
contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Então vamos passar aqui para um caso concreto.
Num primeiro lugar, parecia algo super vantajoso, porque é um apartamento num
prédio super novo, num condomínio com uma infraestrutura completa e está sendo
ofertado em leilão com 50% de desconto em relação ao valor de mercado.
O valor de mercado do imóvel fica ali um pouco mais de 720 mil, que é o valor
da primeira praça.
Em segunda praça, ele está ainda com desconto de 50%, ou seja, por um pouco
mais de 360 mil reais.
Só que tem uma informação, o leilão é dos direitos do fiduciante, ou seja, o
arrematante ficará no lugar do devedor fiduciante.
Vamos ver aqui o campo das observações.
Conforme determinado no edital, o produto da venda será destinado ao pagamento
de débitos de IPTU e condomínio.
E caso o produto da venda não seja o suficiente, a diferença será de
responsabilidade do arrematante.
E o próprio edital, ele apresenta aqui os valores.
Débitos de condomínio, um pouco mais de 140 mil reais, e débitos de IPTU, um
pouco mais de 15 mil reais.
Arredondando a soma aqui de condomínio e IPTU, a gente teria um montante de
dívidas em torno de 160 mil reais.
Repare, o valor da segunda praça, 360 mil.
Então o valor da segunda praça é mais do que suficiente para aquitar condomínio
e IPTU.
E teoricamente, mais nada sobraria para o arrematante.
Porém, é um leilão de direitos do fiduciante e o arrematante ficará no lugar do
devedor fiduciante.
E qual é o detalhe desse imóvel?
Esse imóvel já foi para leilão por mais de 6 vezes e ele pode ir a leilão 10
vezes que provavelmente ninguém vai arrematar.
A não ser que a pessoa não saiba o que é um leilão de direitos do fiduciante.
Vamos ver aqui o que aconteceu quando a caixa se manifestou.
O credor fiduciário nesse imóvel é a caixa.
E a caixa se manifestou, aqui está uma parte da petição dela, informando o
valor da dívida.
E isso é o comum.
Quando o banco é intimado no processo, ele já apresenta o valor da dívida que
tem em aberto.
E foi exatamente isso que a caixa fez.
A caixa apresentou o valor total da dívida, que está em mais de 600 mil reais.
Mas um detalhe, a caixa falou em uma dívida de mais de 600 mil reais atualizada
até setembro de 2017.
Vamos voltar aqui.
Esse leilão, ele foi realizado em 2020.
Então provavelmente esse valor que a caixa apresentou atualizado até 2017, ele
é muito maior.
Porque teve ali a incidência de correção monetária e juros de 2017 até 2020,
que foi quando o leilão foi realizado.
Então o que aconteceria nesse caso?
O arrematante, ele pagaria o valor da segunda praça.
Vamos supor que saísse pelo preço mínimo, esse um pouco mais de 360 mil reais.
Aqueles outros encargos que tem no leilão, que é a comissão do leiloeiro.
E os outros encargos que tem em uma compra de um imóvel, seja de leilão ou seja
de um imóvel tradicional, que é o ITBI e o registro do imóvel em nome do
arrematante.
Só que, por ser um leilão judicial de direitos do fiduciante, o arrematante,
ele também teria que arcar com essa dívida com a caixa, né?
De mais de 600 mil reais.
Isso é que torna esse leilão inviável.
Porque a pessoa pagaria um montante superior a um milhão de reais por um imóvel
que vale 720 mil.
Quem em sã consciência fará um negócio desse?
Ninguém.
Por isso que esse imóvel vai e volta de leilão e ninguém arremata.
Essa é a consequência de um leilão judicial de direitos do fiduciante.
E você precisa ficar bem atento a isso.
Como é que você vai saber se é um leilão judicial de direitos do fiduciante?
Em primeiro lugar, olhando para o edital.
Na maioria dos casos que é um leilão judicial de direitos, o próprio edital
coloca lá a palavra direitos.
Mas vamos supor que o edital não coloque a palavra direitos.
É muito fácil de você saber.
Porque você, obrigatoriamente, para participar de um leilão, deve verificar a
matrícula do imóvel.
E ao verificar a matrícula do imóvel, você iria observar que tem um contrato de
geração fiduciária em vigência.
Ou seja, existe na matrícula do imóvel o registro do contrato de geração
fiduciária e depois não existe o registro do cancelamento desse contrato.
Então esse contrato está valendo.
Ele está em vigência.
E se ele está em vigência, necessariamente, será um leilão judicial de
direitos.
Muita atenção a isso, porque arrematar esse imóvel em leilão judicial de
direitos traz obrigações para o arrematante que é ficar no lugar do devedor
fiduciante.
Agora uma exceção.
Existem juízes que determinam que o valor em aberto da alienação fiduciária
seja paga com o saldo da arrematação após as dívidas preferenciais.
Então tem juiz que decide isso.
Que o valor em aberto que o criador fiduciário tem a receber do devedor
fiduciante vai ser pago ali com o saldo da arrematação depois de quitar dívidas
preferenciais.
Isso aí pode diminuir o valor que vai sobrar para o arrematante.
Mas atenção, você precisa saber se o juiz decidiu assim, analisando o processo
judicial, as decisões daquele processo.
Porque tem juiz que não decide dessa forma e aí realmente o arrematante vai
ficar no lugar do devedor fiduciante assumindo aquelas obrigações por completo,
todo aquele valor por completo que o criador fiduciário tem direito a receber.
E você precisa sempre analisar o que o juiz está decidindo e essa decisão do
juiz para trazer segurança para o arrematante ela tem que ser antes do leilão.
Então você tem que entrar no leilão sabendo se o juiz decidiu assim.
Que o valor em aberto com o criador fiduciário também vai ser pago com o valor
da arrematação ou não.
Se vai sobrar para o arrematante.
Se o juiz falar que o valor vai ser pago com o saldo da arrematação verifique
se o valor da arrematação vai ser suficiente para quitar as dívidas
preferenciais mais o produto que tem em aberto da alienação fiduciária.
Se não for suficiente, considere que o produto vai ficar para você na sua
viabilidade financeira para você saber se aquele leilão vale a pena você
participar ou não.
Muita atenção com o leilão judicial de direitos do devedor fiduciante porque
você pode arrematar uma dívida sem saber.
Então você precisa ficar muito atento.
Qual é o problema da avaliação em um leilão judicial de direitos?
Seja de direitos do fiduciante seja de direitos de um prometente comprador.
Quando o auto de avaliação vai ser elaborado que a gente já sabe que pode ser
por um perito ou por um oficial de justiça nem o perito nem o oficial de
justiça ele vai avaliar somente os direitos ele vai avaliar o valor da
propriedade em si ele vai avaliar o valor de mercado daquela propriedade sem
considerar quanto que tem em aberto daquela dívida.
Então ele avalia o valor da propriedade o imóvel vai a leilão pelo valor da
propriedade mas o imóvel tem dívida de aquisição daquele imóvel e como é leilão
de direitos o arrematante vai ficar no lugar do devedor e vai ter que assumir
essa dívida.
Então muitas vezes esses leilões não são vantajosos exatamente por isso porque
o imóvel foi avaliado no valor de mercado o desconto vai incidir sobre o valor
de mercado mas ainda vai ter uma dívida por fora que é a dívida de aquisição
daquele imóvel somando o valor do lance mais esse valor em aberto da dívida de
aquisição na maioria dos casos em quase 99% dos casos esse valor ultrapassa o
valor de mercado do imóvel e aí não é vantajoso para que você compre esse
imóvel em leilão seja para investimento ou seja para moradia.
Então fique muito, muito, muito atento em leilão judicial de direitos do
devedor fiduciante a consequência é você como arrematante ficar no lugar do
devedor fiduciante e assumir a obrigação que aquele devedor tem com o credor
fiduciário sinal alerta para esse tipo de leilão o segundo caso mais comum é o
direito do prometente comprador e aí esse caso se subdivide em dois casos
primeiro, a pessoa comprou um imóvel pagou o valor integral pelo imóvel ao
vendedor mas não registrou esse contrato na matrícula tecnicamente para a nossa
legislação quem compra e não registra não é proprietário do imóvel porque a
nossa lei diz que o proprietário é aquele que tem o registro em seu nome mas é
inegável que essa pessoa que comprou pagou tudo e não registrou tem direito de
aquisição sobre aquele imóvel porque basta que ela registre o imóvel em seu
nome que o imóvel vai ser dela então é o mesmo caso vamos supor que essa pessoa
que comprou e não registrou ela tem dívidas, foi condenada judicialmente e a
justiça ao procurar bens só encontra esse que não foi registrado corretamente a
justiça então vai determinar o leilão judicial de direitos desse imóvel da
mesma forma consequência, se constar a informação de que o contrato está
quitado o arrematante terá que regularizar a transferência anterior para depois
registrar a sua arrematação, por que isso acontece?
porque a matrícula do imóvel segue uma continuidade, então por exemplo A vendeu
para B B registrou o imóvel corretamente B é visto pela nossa legislação como
proprietário B vendeu esse imóvel para C C não registrou essa compra, então
tecnicamente B ainda é visto como proprietário, porque C não existe na
matrícula do imóvel e a nossa lei diz que proprietário é quem tem o registro em
seu nome, como C não tem, C não é visto como proprietário, mas C tem direito de
aquisição, basta que ele registre o imóvel em seu nome que ele vai ser o
proprietário então ele tem direito de aquisição daquela propriedade quando C é
condenado judicialmente na justiça para o pagamento de uma dívida e a justiça
leva esse imóvel que C tem direito de aquisição, esse vai ser um leilão
judicial de direitos, quem arrematar vai ter a informação na carta de
arrematação que o imóvel saiu de C e foi para o arrematante só que o
arrematante não conseguiria registrar essa carta de arrematação de pronto na
matrícula, por quê?
porque C não consta na matrícula então não poderia constar a informação na
matrícula de que o imóvel saiu de C para o arrematante, sem que C conste
naquela matrícula o que o arrematante vai ter que fazer?
vai ter que regularizar antes de registrar a carta de arrematação, essa compra
que C fez e não registrou como que o arrematante vai ter que fazer isso?
qual é a consequência de ter que fazer isso?
o arrematante pode ter que pagar dois ETBIs e dois registros, porque quando a
gente registra o imóvel a consequência do registro é pagar o ETBI e pagar o
registro para consolidar a transferência de uma pessoa para a outra então o
arrematante teria que regularizar essa compra que C fez e não registrou, isso
pode implicar ali o pagamento de ETBI e registro relativo ao compra de C, para
depois conseguir registrar a sua carta de arrematação e pagar novamente ETBI e
registro pode ser que você, como interessado naquele leilão analisando esses
custos extras, ainda assim entenda que é um leilão vantajoso e decida
participar, pode ser que analisando esse custo você decida que não é um leilão
vantajoso e aí você fica de fora daquele leilão, parta para o próximo o segundo
caso seria o seguinte, o contrato de cumpre-venda ainda não foi quitado
contrato de cumpre-venda entre particulares, eles também podem estabelecer
pagamento parcelado, e nesses casos o vendedor só entregará o documento que é o
termo de quitação da promessa de cumpre-venda para o comprador registrar a
propriedade ao final do parcelamento qual é a consequência de participar de um
leilão desse tipo?
O arrematante também ficará no lugar do prometente comprador, e qual é o
principal problema aqui desse leilão?
A lei diz que o prometente vendedor somente será necessariamente intimado do
processo do leilão se a promessa de cumpre-venda estiver registrada na
matrícula, e nem sempre é isso que as pessoas fazem, a maioria das pessoas
quando estabelece ali uma venda entre particulares de forma parcelada, elas
fazem essa promessa de cumpre-venda e não registram na matrícula, fica ali um
contrato entre as partes elas deixam para registrar somente quando o valor for
todo pago e aí sim for acontecer a transferência da propriedade do vendedor
para o comprador então se a promessa de cumpre-venda não estiver registrada, e
na maioria dos casos não tá, o vendedor não vai ser intimado no processo do
leilão, e a consequência disso é que o arrematante não vai saber qual é o valor
em aberto que tem ali daquele contrato de cumpre-venda, e aí não devemos
participar desse leilão, porque a gente só deve participar do leilão que a
gente tem plena ciência da possibilidade de sobrar ou não dívida por
arrematante ao contrário disso, devemos ficar de fora, porque pra nossa
viabilidade financeira, a gente tem que calcular todos os custos que a
arrematação vai ter, só assim a gente vai saber se determinada arrematação é
vantajosa ou não, a consequência máxima então desse leilão seria também que o
arrematante ficará no lugar do prometente comprador e sobrará para o
arrematante o valor da dívida do contrato de cumpre-venda, assim como acontece
lá em um leilão judicial de direitos do vendedor fiduciante, o arrematante aqui
nesse caso também vai ser responsável por pagar o montante em aberto do
contrato de cumpre-venda, além do valor da arrematação.
Como é que você vai saber se é um leilão judicial de direitos quando a pessoa
comprou o imóvel e não registrou em seu nome?
É muito simples, você vai olhar o nome do executado que consta no edital do
leilão e naquele processo judicial e ao procurar o nome do executado na
matrícula do imóvel, você não vai achar, justamente porque a compra não foi
registrada e na matrícula só consta aquilo que está registrado então toda vez
que você olhar o nome do executado, procurar o nome do executado na matrícula
do imóvel e não achar, aquilo ali é um leilão judicial de direitos e aí pode
ser um contrato de cumpre-venda quitado ou um contrato de cumpre-venda que não
foi quitado, como a gente acabou de estudar anteriormente aqui na aula.
Existem também outros tipos de leilões judiciais de direitos um exemplo deles é
o leilão judicial de direitos hereditários o que significa?
Alguém é herdeiro de uma herança e tem direitos sobre os imóveis ali que foram
deixados naquela herança mas ainda não aconteceu a partilha o herdeiro ainda
não consta como proprietário daquele imóvel, mas como já tem o processo de
herança ali em trâmite o inventário judicial já se tem ciência de que o
herdeiro vai ter direito a determinado imóvel, quanto ele vai ter direito de
determinado imóvel isso aí também pode ocasionar leilão judicial de direitos
hereditários sobre aquilo que ele tinha direito a consequência é exatamente a
mesma, o herdeiro ele não consta na matrícula, primeiro o arrematante vai ter
que regularizar essa transferência de imóvel ao herdeiro pra depois registrar a
carta de arrematação, isso também traz consequências como pagamento duplo de
TBI, pagamento duplo de registro do imóvel Qual é a minha opinião particular
sobre o leilão judicial de direitos?
Eu não participo porque eu viso sempre participar dos leilões que são de mais
fácil resolução após o leilão, porque o meu objetivo após o leilão é de forma
mais rápida possível vender o imóvel ou alugar o imóvel de acordo com o que eu
tiver definido antes do leilão e esses leilões judiciais de direitos eles têm
uma burocracia a mais após o leilão, porque no leilão judicial de direitos do
devedor fiduciante o arrematante vai ter que correr atrás ali do banco pra
quitar aquele contrato de alienação fiduciário em aberto, isso aí nem sempre é
rápido, é um procedimento burocrático, porque tratar com o banco ali sempre
envolve um pouco de burocracia.
Segundo lugar se for um leilão judicial de direitos do prometente comprador e
tiver quitado, mesmo aquele que não tem a possibilidade de sobrar dívida ali
pro arrematante o arrematante ainda assim vai ter que correr atrás da
documentação dessa compra anterior e isso envolve um vendedor que é
completamente desconhecido pro arrematante.
Por quê?
Porque o vendedor ele não fez parte daquele processo só quem fez parte do
processo é o comprador que comprou do vendedor e não registrou.
E quem é esse vendedor?
Onde está esse vendedor?
Muitas vezes nós como arrematantes não sabemos disso e aí também vai ter uma
dificuldade pra encontrar esse vendedor pra conseguir antes registrar aquela
compra que não foi registrada.
E como a gente não tem na maioria dos casos como saber onde está aquele
vendedor, quem é aquele vendedor, qual é o contato do vendedor eu prefiro não
participar pra depois não ter que ter esse trabalho a mais.
Então eu aviso sempre participar dos leilões que são de mais fácil resolução.
E quais são esses leilões?
Os leilões da propriedade do imóvel e não dos direitos da propriedade.
Então fique muito atento sempre que for um leilão de direitos, saiba qual é a
consequência de um leilão de direitos que pode sobrar uma dívida a mais ali
naquele imóvel que foi aquela dívida da aquisição do imóvel pelo devedor que
não pagou a integralidade ou que não registrou o imóvel em seu nome.
Você precisa ficar muito atento a isso tem que ter muita atenção nesses leilões
judiciais de direitos do imóvel.